my heart my slaves killed job all right
so I'm with Luke Meyer and he's the
director of breaking a monster he
followed around the metal band unlocking
the truth tell me how you got involved
in this project what made you want to
decide to all these kids around
originally made a short film on them
that was for an online energy magazine
is all video based and that was not only
a good experience but went over really
well about a million people watched the
first month it was online things started
to move really quickly for them and one
of the things that ideas of all the
stuff they're trying to put together was
a idea of a promotional documentary and
some band of their family came back to
me and my producer Tom Davis about
making that and they're teenagers now
they're so young at you've known them
when they were even younger tell me a
little bit about the first time you met
them and how that interaction was what
what did you say what did they say I
think I interviewed him right away i
think when we shot the short the first
thing i did was we just sat down and
started talking I mean there were a lot
younger than I am yeah really shy and
then you went and shot a bunch of things
to do much more that was more fun the
big challenge is that they are kids in
there like they're kind of all over the
place I mean they're really personable
kids so it was it's easy to connect with
it matters on who you are and who you
feel that you can be I wouldn't say it's
racist but it is how people stereotype
in their head